ahora vamos a empezar a pensar en la
cantidad de formas de hacer algo bueno
la cantidad de formas de ordenar algunas
cosas así es que digamos que estamos en
una pequeña reunión de cuatro personas
entonces tenemos a la persona
a la persona ve la persona ese y la
persona ve tenemos a estas cuatro
personas en la reunión y digamos que no
se conocen y se quieren conocer entonces
cada una de estas personas quiere
saludar al resto de las personas de la
reunión entonces la pregunta es cuántos
saludos en total va a haber en esta
reunión porque cuando estamos asumiendo
que cada una de estas personas va a
saludarse con las otras personas
exactamente una vez
así es que te recomiendo que le pongas
pausa el vídeo y trates de encontrar la
respuesta voy a suponer que ya lo
intentaste y ahora sí vamos a contar
cuántos saludos hay en total podemos
pensarlo de esta forma
a persona
bueno cada persona tiene que saludar al
resto de las personas de la reunión
entonces tiene que saludar a b y tiene
que saludar hace y tiene que saludar a
de entonces a saludar a tres personas y
ahora ve a cuántas personas va a saludar
pues podríamos decir que ve también
tiene que saludar a tres personas tiene
que saludar y ya sé ya de entonces está
en tres saludos y la persona se también
está entre saludos porque tiene que
saludar a b y ab y de la misma forma le
tiene que saludar a tres personas de
ésta en tres saludos entonces tenemos a
cuatro personas y cada una de esas
personas se encuentra en tres saludos
así es que podríamos pensar que hay
cuatro por tres saludos
lu2
aunque hay 4 por 3 es 12 entonces
tendríamos 12 saludos ahora te
recomiendo que le pongas una pausa y
pienses si realmente hay 12 saludos ok
tú qué opinas
pues es una muy buena idea es dibujar
todos estos saludos este argumento fue
demasiado rápido a ver vamos a empezar
dibujando todos los saludos en los que
se encuentra a gay tiene que saludar a b
entonces tenemos el saludo de a con ve a
también tiene que saludar hace entonces
tenemos el saludo de conce y hay de
también se tienen que saludar saludo a d
así es que por el momento tenemos tres
saludos que también lo teníamos por acá
pero con calma hay que seguir viendo
esto ahora vamos a ver en qué saludos se
encuentra ve
se tiene que saludar con a b se tiene
que saludar con c b se tiene que saludar
con d y luego c
se tiene que saludar con el cs tiene que
saludar con b y c se tiene que saludar
con d y d tiene que saludar a y b tiene
que saludarse con b y d tiene que
saludarse con c y aquí puedes decir
inicial acabas de enumerar 12 saludos
pero hay algo muy interesante aquí y es
que estamos contando dos veces algunos
saludos así es que te recomiendo que le
pongas una pausa del vídeo otra vez y
veas en dónde es que estamos contando
dos veces bueno estoy suponiendo otra
vez que ya lo intentaste pero el chiste
aquí es recordar que queremos contar
cada saludo exactamente una vez porque
por aquí estamos contando el saludo de
una vez pero por aquí tenemos el saludo
de a y estos 2 saludos en realidad son
exactamente el mismo saludo ok no
importa si está saludando bebé o sí ve
está saludando a a estos son exactamente
el mismo saludo así es que al saludo / b
y a lo estamos contando dos veces y lo
mismo pasa por aquí tenemos el saludo b
akon ce y tenemos aquí al saludo de
second pero estamos diciendo que las
personas se deben de saludar una sola
vez y estos dos saludos son exactamente
el mismo saludo y lo estamos contando
dos veces y lo mismo pasa entre este
saludo y este otro saludo son
exactamente el mismo saludo y si estamos
contando todos estos saludos dos veces
que deberíamos de hacer con esto pues lo
que tenemos que hacer es dividirlo entre
dos que vivir entre dos porque aquí
estamos contando cuando a saludar y aquí
estamos contando cuando de saludar a
entonces cada uno de los saludos los
estamos contando dos veces
lo que tenemos que dividir aquí entre
dos si es que cuatro por tres entre dos
es lo mismo que 12 entre
26 entonces tenemos 6 saludos
lu2 y si queremos ver los 6 saludos por
aquí lo único que tenemos que hacer es
eliminar los saludos que ya se contaron
entonces a ver a de idea
son el mismo saludo luego hace y sea
también son el mismo saludo a de idea
son el mismo veces y se ve son el mismo
bebé y debe son el mismo y cede y dice
son el mismo y entonces nos quedan 1 2 3
4 5 6 saludos